an addiction recovery non-profit is  bringing back a president who left after  sexual abuse allegations vegas stronger  says they did an internal investigation  into dave marlin and have cleared him of  any wrongdoing a former employee filed a  lawsuit against him accusing him of  sexually assaulting and harassing her  repeatedly this is a story the i-team  covered last year court records show a  settlement was reached in the lawsuit  just last week but does not declare the  amount vegas stronger also says marlin  was cleared criminally we have asked the  metro police  department about a criminal  investigation and are awaiting a  response